ми ж2 ти ж не турецько влада протру мало
кореспондентів поганого та німецького
газета dewalt деніза юджі ляпи даруєш
там тепер журналіста проведуть у сізо до
видно з турецьким закону дасть вами можна
просидить знову руки
40 3 ridge на мою частку за коли адже
ширині пропаганди на курас терор та
стейшн та організації то з буринь а
народу та внести international the human
rights watch
ризику за suju втираєш журналіста геть та
стрибуна не юджин по стежках він і милися
турецька влада через приховані дж ну
статтю про фінансові махінації зятя
президента тури ціни міністра енергетики
брата алба іраку ворота турецької змії
через страх про ігри пресі ями уникав
на вигляд у мене пройшла moneymail і алба
ірака та гіду віддав його про чесність
душах спорідненості
німецький журналіст і не мовчати та
панує демонстрації на піт ринку
колега данис юджин народи все впевненим
а я посуну німецько-турецьке громадян
ству winters німецькі журналісти це та
зараз біля проходу влади в 2000 іншому
роті партії президента реджепа тайїпу
ердогана по трапах до турецького сізо
берліні також ризику за суду віляр з
концерту не метшин та ангела меркель
сказала що рішення про сезон для і
джеррі дуже про ігри і що c і душі
розшир увала а міністр закордонних справ
р-н зігмар габріель
назвавши його занадто з злодіям цьому не
адекватним рішенням він має біля що тест на
наша підлога і забираючи жадібного приводу
дозволять і його свобода на такі довгі
годину вінду брюссель назву сьогодні на
турецькій вуст піти ми спати його і
що мислить рішенню будь-якої справи
без вигляд атома свободі слова even
знову на за баром вийшовши на волю
мир . get why do we fight сонця п'яний
через переслідування журналістів анкарі
закидають дисконт вид принципу vs
а ти можеш висоти на не увійти процес
євроінтеграції турет шини